comment changer de métier ça c'est une
vraie question delphine vidal auquel
vous vous vous répondez très souvent
comment faire aussi de sa passion
finalement son métier quelles sont les
étapes pour effectuer sur une mention
changement professionnel faut déjà
commencer à à bien ce estimé comme on
dit parce que souvent il paraît qu'on se
sous-estiment alors c'est vrai ou c'est
faux c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on sait
sous-estiment au quotidien j'ai envie de
dire on a des projets mais on sait pas
trop comment s'y prendre et la question
qui est récurrente chez nous c'est ce
que je vais arriver à faire ma
reconversion professionnelle alors on va
voir en images ce que ça peut donner non
conversion professionnels des exemples
précis puis on va partager le témoignage
de gerald de kate avec nos sur ce
plateau mais d'abord changer de métier
mais pas de télé s'il vous plaît c'est
possible voici quelques bons conseils
pour réussir sa reconversion
professionnelle ben est plus dans la
charcuterie je me suis reconverti je
fais dans le stylisme maclin aujourd'hui
la reconversion professionnelle à la
côte
56 % des actifs ont déjà changé
d'orientation professionnelle
et parmi ceux qui n'ont pas tenté
l'expérience 35 % se disent prêts à
changer de métier dans l'année qui vient
envie de nouveauté de faire évoluer sa
carrière ou de donner un nouveau souffle
à sa vie que vous ayez 30 ans ou plus de
50 ans que vous soyez en cdi en cdd ou
sans emploi avec ou sans diplôme c'est
possible mais attention une reconversion
professionnelle réussie ne se fait pas à
la légère
cela nécessite de bien réfléchir à ses
motivations et les adapter à la réalité
notre conseil commencez par faire un
bilan de compétences cela vous permettra
d'établir d'un professionnel vos atouts
pour votre futur métier
plusieurs organismes peuvent le financer
et rassurez vous votre employeur actuel
n'en sera rien que vous connaissiez déjà
votre futur métier ou non dans tous les
cas ce qui compte c'est de s'orienter
vers un métier qui recrute et qui a de
l'avenir ouvrir une agence de voyages
c'est sympa sauf qu'avec internet ça ne
fait plus du tout recettes oubliées mais
qui dit reconversion professionnelle dix
formations se pose donc la question du
financement
n'hésitez pas à vous servir de votre
compte professionnel deux formations cpr
créé en janvier dernier qui vous donne
accès à des formations qui peuvent être
entièrement prise en charge et même
rémunérés pas mal alors on se
reconvertit la formation des mois c'est
le succès assuré pour réussir sa
reconversion en effet c'est le succès
assuré
oui c'est sympa pour la reconversion
professionnelle effectivement là pour
mettre tous les atouts de son côté
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire en premier en
premier il faut prendre le temps de
réfléchir
souvent les gens ont envie de changer de
métier ont un rêve ont envie de faire de
leur passion leur métier demain moi ce
que je conseille c'est prendre le temps
voilà même si actuellement vous êtes en
emploi ça se passe pas très bien prenez
quand même le temps de réfléchir
il ya des étapes à suivre et il faut pas
se précipiter faut vraiment réfléchir et
c'est entouré personnes qui peuvent nous
accompagner
j'en connais qui a dû bien réfléchir il
est à côté de vous c'est gérald tir haut
en quelques mots pour faire un résumé
rapide auparavant vous étiez conducteurs
de transports en commun
vous avez dû arrêter à cause d'un
problème de santé et à partir de ce
moment qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour
entamer le chemin vers la reconversion
des gens on passe par des phases de
doute parce que bien sûr c'est le
changement
forcément ça induit des phases de doute
on se demande qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
après ça implique aussi quand moi je
suis père de famille donc s'implique
aussi commandement je suis venir aux
besoins de ma famille de quelle manière
on se dit bon on passe d'un métier puis
on se dit mais comment se réinventer
demain en fait qu'est-ce que dans quoi
je vais me projeté demain est en fait
c'est tout ce qu'on a vu avec votre
emporté un reportage voilà exactement
c'est tout un processus qui se fait avec
un accompagnement de personnes de
structure et enfin comme c'est rare
qu'un reportage un bilan de compétences
pour arriver à ce parcours de
reconversion professionnelle vers
quelque chose je rajouterais par un
métier qui a de l'avenir et un métier
qui nous plaît aussi sur nous j'ai
entendu accompagnement j'entends du
bilan de compétence va commencer par
l'accompagnement delphine puisque en
l'occurrence avec l'afpa on est
accompagné ça
se passe comment alors on a l'exemple de
gérald qui est là on verra quel métier
il est allé mais mais mais d'abord ça se
passe comment l'accompagnement et bien
c'est très simple il suffit de venir
nous rencontrer j'ai envie de dire tous
les jeudis matins on propose aux gens de
venir nous rencontrer à 9 heures ça se
passe dans toutes les offres aux
désastres dans tous les centres afpa de
bourgogne franche comté donc on fait des
réunions d'information collectives qu'on
appelle chez nous un déclic informations
donc si on veut repousser ouvert à tout
le monde vous venez à 9 heures on vous
accueille on vous renseigne on vous
explique rapidement parce qu'il lave pas
comment fonctionnent les formations
qu'on propose
et puis comment on entre en formation
comment comment on va être rémunéré plus
tard enfin voilà on prend un petit temps
pour vous expliquer tout ça soit c'est
totalement gratuit
ça c'est totalement gratuit ok j'ai
entendu bilan de compétences dans la
voix de gerald vous vous en avez fait
exactement qu'est ce qu'ils ont été
sorties de ce bilan de compétences en
quelques mots quelques mots en fait
c'est en fait on apprend à se connaître
plus en profondeur au niveau
professionnel mais aussi au niveau
personnel et aussi vers quel domaine
peut peut-être aspirer à devenir
d'accord rappelle que vous étés
conducteurs de transports s'est toujours
pas le métier que vous avez fait mais
volontairement je vais y arriver
volontairement je reviens vers vous
parce que le bilan de compétences ça
peut faire peur se retrouver sur les
bancs de l'école
dans le tas de gérald s'est passé 35 ans
voilà c'est pas évident ça peut être
bien bien plus bien plus loin on l'a vu
aussi à tout agencé miscibles exactement
alors le bilan de compétences moi je le
conseille pas ce que c'est un temps
comprend un temps de réflexion comprend
et comme le comme le disait un monsieur
c'est l'objectif c'est prendre un temps
de réflexion sur vos aspirations
professionnelles mais surtout sur vos
aspirations personnelles de votre vie
vous évoluez vous allez avoir des
enfants ils vont grandir on se dit bah
voilà maintenant je vais penser à moi
l'objectif c'est de se dire voilà
quelles sont les qualités personnelles
de quoi je suis capable de reprendre
confiance en soi et d'ouvrir j'ai envie
de dire le champ des possibles et voir
vers où on peut aller donc bilan de
compétences on peut le faire en combien
de temps ça dépend en moyenne à un
accompagnement ces 24 heures sur
plusieurs sur plusieurs mois
c'est c'est un travail vraiment c'est un
investissement personnel sur le temps de
travail hors temps de travail ça dépend
des structures qui vous accompagnent et
voilà c'est une phase vraiment
importante
je vous propose d'écouter la la question
de laëtitia à la pression téléphone elle
se dit tiens je vais vous poser une
question sur la reconversion
professionnelle
écoute et qui à 39 ans professeur des
écoles
j'aurais voulu savoir comment financer
une reconversion professionnelle
nécessite une reprise d'études lorsqu'on
est dans la fonction publique alors là
c'est le cas de la fonction publique un
mais celles et ceux qui nous regardent
tour pas tous dans la fonction publique
on peut répondre à laetitia et puis
généralement à tous ceux qui sont avec
nous des films alors la fonction
publique
c'est un bon exemple c'est c'est
l'exemple le plus compliqué
malheureusement parce qu'effectivement
il ya beaucoup de contraintes dans la
fonction publique on doit des années à
la fonction publique donc on peut pas se
libérer aussi facilement qu'un salarié
classique j'ai envie de vous dire
après le financement va ça va être le
compte personnel de formation comme on a
vu dans le reportage un squale spurs
alors le cpf en fait c'est un compteur
d'heures enfin qui est converti en euros
maintenant que vous cumulez à chaque
fois que vous travaillez tout simplement
qui vous appartient qu'est part attachée
à un contrat de travail mais qui est
rattachée à un individu donc vous
travaillez dans une entreprise vous
cumulez des heures que vous emmenez avec
vous et que vous échangez dans un centre
de formation contre des heures de
formation j'ai entendu dire que ce
n'était pas automatique se cpf il
fallait aller s'inscrire sur internet
sécurité sociale à gratter et qu'en
retour on savait précisément finalement
notre package combien en avez d'argent
dans le coffre dans la vallée tout à
fait mon compte point gouv.fr vous allez
vous inscrire il ya voilà un login et un
mot de passe
quelques petites questions personnelles
sur vous votre numéro de sécurité
sociale
vos activités professionnelles et puis
ensuite ben voilà on va vous dire ce
dont vous dispensez je reviens sur vous
gérez le tir au fait retrouver sur les
bancs de l'école je le disais tout à
l'heure
passé 35 ans et pas forcément évident à
eux
oui et non je dirai pas ce que c'est pas
retourner sur les bancs de l'école parce
que on est devenus des adultes et en
fait c'est tout des structures qui sont
voués en fait pour les adultes en fait
donc on il ya tout accompagnement puis
au niveau de la formation
voilà vous prend en compte l'adulte en
tant que lui en tant de ses besoins
le besoin de lui donner du sens aussi à
ce qui fait et ce qui la formation ce
qu' elle va lui apporter en fait en
termes de compétences vous étiez dans
l'ancien temps si j'ose dire conducteurs
de bus aujourd'hui vous allez vers quoi
va je m'oriente pour devenir formateur
justement
je suis là en ce moment à l'afp âge fait
le titre professionnel fp&a formateur
professionnel donc ça veut dire un
formateur pour l'insertion c'est ça pas
faux non c'était pour formateurs on va
être un formateur lambda je veux dire
mais après moi moi je m'oriente vers
l'insertion professionnelle le domaine
d'activité qui me passionne l'insertion
professionnelle je propose d'écouter
notre témoignage
on vous a entendu gerald cette fois ci
c'est c'est fabien qui lui est devenu
entrepreneur
regardez écoutez you du coup moi c'est
fabien j'ai fait des études de génie
chimique j'ai travaillé l'on est là haut
pendant quelques
pendant quelques mois je me suis très
vite rendu compte que là le salariat
c'était vraiment pas pour moi du coup
j'ai commencé à entreprendre dans
plusieurs domaines j'ai acquis pas mal
de compétences qui ont permis vraiment
orienté pour me reconvertir une dernière
fois et créer ma société dans la
création de business justement gêner les
personnes à créer leur business
indépendant et faire le parcours que
j'ai fait globalement donc forcément je
suis payé grâce à mes compétences donc
nettement mieux et à ma juste valeur en
tout cas je trouve et globalement ce que
je faisais avant un mois maintenant je
peux le faire en quelques jours et puis
même en termes d'épanouissement je suis
d'autres moyens comme ça et je suis
vraiment très content de m'être de m
reconverti professionnellement en soi
qui revient le plus souvent c'est
l'épanouissement et à vous regarder
serrés le tyrolien j'ai envie de dire
j'ai l'impression que c'est gratifiant
d'avoir osé
oui c'est gratifiant parce que en fait
on a le sentiment moi personnellement
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir trouvé ma
vocation
tout ce parcours de reconversion plus
toutes les personnes que j'ai
rencontrées les structures qui m'ont
aidé dans ce parcours font
qu'aujourd'hui oui j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir trouvé ma vocation
donc je peux le faire je vais y arriver
j'ai un statut dans ces cas là d'être
candidat
ça se passe comment alors ça dépend du
statut qu'on a au début c'est à dire que
si on est salarié on reste salarié si on
est demandeur d'emploi en reste
demandeur d'emploi quand on est en
formation les stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle d'une rémunération en
fonction du statut
si vous êtes salarié vous conservez
votre salaire de salariés tout
simplement et si vous êtes demandeur
d'emploi soit vous avez des droits au
chômage qui perdure pendant la formation
soit vous avez des allocations région le
meilleur des conseils que vous puissiez
donner à celles et ceux qui sont avec
nous et qui n'existera rue pourquoi pas
après tout pourquoi pas changer de
métier on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus
linéaire
une carrière on reste rarement dans la
même entreprise tout au long de sa
carrière
c'est quoi c'est déjà de se prendre en
mains de se dire oui je vais y arriver
oui je vais tenter oui je vais essayer
oui je vais me renseigner
le premier pas je dirais c'est d'aller
se renseigner ça coûte rien ça n'engage
à rien donc venez poser des questions
n'y a pas de questions idiotes tu as
envie de dire donc venez vous renseigner
venez nous rencontrer
on fait d'ailleurs une journée portes
ouvertes prochainement le 26 septembre
dans tous les centres afpa
donc venez poser vos questions venait
rencontrer des centres de formation et
puis après on verra
la question que vous pose le plus
souvent vous c'est votre quotidien vous
rencontrez des gens comme comme gerald
qui décide de changer de vie
qu'est ce que vous leur dites à ces gens
là je le redis prend leur temps je leur
dis de s'entourer parce que
effectivement on a envie de partir dans
son projet donc on a envie d'y arriver
tout seul faut admettre aussi qu'on peut
avoir besoin dead et à plusieurs on est
plus fort j'ai envie donc voilà prendre
le temps de faire les choses prendre le
temps de se poser et puis et puis
avancer pas à pas confiance